my good buddy Adam Schefter how are you
Adam how you doing I'm doing fine are
you in the car right now between New
York and Bristol like I saw in the real
sports beat so you're in that car I I am
in the car right now between picking up
my son's car and basically going home
okay
so you'reyou're you're in it are you
really calling in on the very rare
24-hour period where you're not doing
anything other than just being yourself
and a dad that really you know it's
funny it's funny yesterday I got an
email from ESPN they're like hey just
want to let you know we switched your
NBA assignment next week we were doing
the Cavaliers Brooklyn next game and
Cleveland next Wednesday but we're
sending you the Minnesota to do the
rockets and Timberwolves and I said well
that's news on both fronts nobody told
me about the person's timing this is the
first on the area the second assignment
I'm now trying to figure out if I can
juggle my schedule enough to go to
Minnesota next week to do a little unbe
a action next week we'll see well you
just love I mean you'd taken that on
because you love the Association right I
mean you'd love the NBA you know I
started playing NBA thanks to basketball
a few years back and it's kind of become
my vice and my hobby and it's something
I just love and so because I follow it
so closely there I could tell you any
player on your team and and so they
bought for me the opportunity to do a
few games and sidelines and it's just
it's always fun to me I considered a
professional vacation you just show up
there and you go meet with the coaches
and the players they're like what are
you doing here no you get lost or
something like that they don't quite
understand it so it to me it's very
enjoyable and it's one night and I'm not
responsible for you know being first on
where Anthony Davis is traded Kyrie
Irving is going or whether the Memphis
please Mike Conley and Marcus aw don't
worry about that I'll leave that to
loach okay I can go watch the game enjoy
the game you talk about the game and
have a little bit of fun I love it
that's great so you're like the Bo
Jackson of football and basketball
reporting that's your hobby and
footballs I guess your job in a way so
let's get to that job a little bit here
what do you think the aftermath
of Super Bowl 53 is going to be what do
you think well I think it puts a crown
on the Patriots legacy it cements the
idea that they are the most impressive
dynasty that we've ever seen in football
I mean you could talk about the Packers
in the 60s and the Steelers in the 70s
and the Cowboys in the 80s and the
Niners in the 90s or whatever it was -
the established 90s out whatever you
want to know yeah right - even Cowboys -
but none of those teams did that in the
salary cap era and so everything that's
going on here is designed to defeat
exactly what New England is doing and if
you just go back to last offseason and
you look at all the talent that they
lost at that point in time how many
teams which would survive the loss of
their starting left tackle who would go
on to sign a huge deal with the New York
Giants the way that the Patriots did in
losing mates shoulder now that was one
huge loss that they were able to
overcome how about Malcom Butler a guy
that made the play in the Super Bowl
going to Tennessee how about we only had
until we came through with someone who
collects plays in the playoffs leaves
and goes your division rival the Miami
Dolphins how about your biggest play
making running back the only was going
to Tennessee how about trading away your
starting wide receiver your best wide
receiver Brandin cooks for a first-round
pick how about losing the first round
pick during the season
Isiah went to a torn Achilles how about
having Julian Edelman suspended how
about having Josh Borden suspended how
about I think all that happened never
saying boo about it and just going on in
winning another world title this is
crazy
you know it really is crazy Adam cuz
obviously you know we're both Michigan
men and you know I was even talking
about this with Charles Woodson on my
show last week and Ty Law getting into
the Hall of Fame nobody saw the Brady
stuff coming nobody nobody and he's the
goat I mean that's it they're talking
about him and Jordan now you know what I
mean like we're no longer comparing him
to anybody in in the NFL's history we're
talking about him and versus Michael
Jordan now essentially
I mean look Jordan in the finals were
six you know and Brady is six and three
in those games and you know by the way
if you know and if we go both ways right
but let's flip it Brady's way for a
moment let's say that Asante Samuel
holds on to that interception against
the Giants right before David Tyree
makes the catch because if a southeast
family who led the league in
interceptions that year holds on to that
play that one pass that was in his hands
the undefeated season is in the books
Brady quarterback the wall 19 and all
year that we've seen and they're seven
in two in the Super Bowls and then the
people I magnin doesn't feel that long
sideline pass Tamara Manning him maybe
there ain't one but the Giants their
credit deserved the two rings that they
got so they get it twice and then the
third Super Bowl losses two Eagles looks
good one anyway now you could say okay
well the Patriots are fortunate to beat
the Seahawks on the now come but we'll
pick which maybe they were and they were
fortunate to come back against the
fountains and overtime which maybe they
were but they're six in three which is
probably what they should be when all
getting done so I think go to your way
sometimes they don't go your way but
when I was watching Steve Young talk on
NFL primetime nights of the night he
said something great he said that the
MVP of that game should have been Bill
Belichick because it was his crowning
achievement as a coach in those Super
Bowls coming up with a game plan that
slowed that offense and held it to three
total points so they've won Super Bowls
now in all sorts of ways with special
teams without fence now with defense and
they did this in a way that you never
would think that an offense coached by
Sean McVeigh with that many weapons
could go into her 3 points 3 points and
who thought that the Patriots who by the
way was their defensive coordinator Matt
Patricia as well last year losing their
defense score nearby floors this year as
well
we're going to go hold that team without
a touchdown
Terry game it's amazing Adam Schefter
here on the Rich Eisen show so what is
when I say the aftermath is well the
copycat that comes out of here everybody
wants a piece of whoever wins at all
obviously you mentioned Flores who was
again spectacular in his role now going
to the Dolphins and it seems you know
the one of the best lines this year was
in the playoffs from Wade Phillips
saying you know my son also knows Sean
McVeigh maybe you want to hire him to
that coaching job what do you think the
copycat aspect coming out of this is
going to be Adam well I would just say
is that the the Patriots coaching staff
has kind of been picked through over the
years and I still believe that josh
mcdaniels would be a great head coach
and this year he interview with the
Green Bay Packers and I thought a lot of
people thought including me that he
might wind up with that job and they
went with Matt Lafleur instead so I mean
everybody wants a piece of the patriot
way but nobody nobody has been able to
duplicate it they're gone and hired all
sorts of coaches out of their Romeo
Crennel and Charlie Weis and Josh
McDaniels at one point in time and Matt
Patricia what we just think of all
coaches and Capehart nobody's been able
to do what Bill Belichick has been able
to do there in Foxborough and so I don't
know the aftermath is I don't think
anybody can duplicate I don't think
anybody's gonna try and duplicate I
think when you stand back from afar and
admire a creation of what is I think the
greatest football dynasty until history
I had Tom Curren on yesterday had him
and he said that when the afterglow
finally wears off that Belichick is
gonna see over the steering wheel that
he's definitely gonna still be the coach
longer than Brady we assumed will play
and that there might be some sort of
issue giving Brady a monster extension
that he clearly would deserve how do you
see all that playing out now in the
future here for New England
well the thing with bill rich is that
there's no sign of letting up he just
loves it so much now at some point I'm
even decide you know what I've had
enough but I just can't see his life
without football because it's that
important to him and it drives him that
much and he is probably the most
tireless person I know the most tireless
person I know and have seen because he
just he's incredible like that and I
don't care how old he is now or how
young he is but you just keep it going
and his appetite for it never seen so as
long as he wants to do it now at some
point time maybe he wants to move it to
a Bill Parcells type of role where you
want to lord over a football team but he
does anyway he just doesn't say coach as
opposed to being an executive so if he
wants to do that it's something I'm sure
I don't know that two years from now
five years from not saying yes now
nobody knows not even him so I would
assume that he would outlast Brady
that's for Brady's contract what does it
matter they have all the cap space they
need anyway the caps going up a ton
anyway and if you want to pick Tom Brady
for all that he has accomplished which
is not the patriot way so big he's the
one guy in NFL history that you can do
that for because nobody's ever done what
he has and nobody ever will do what he
has so if you want to reward him time
and if you don't you think Tom Brady's
gonna argue with you whether he deserves
to be paid 28 million or 32 million or
36 like what does that mean nothing it
doesn't mean anything so I don't know I
know we want answers to these questions
but then really are no answers right now
you know that girl loves football Tom's
gonna be taken care of and well let it
all play out the way it does shefter
here on the Rich Eisen show we'll talk
about his HBO feature in a second some
quick hitters here what what happens
with Nick Foles and the Eagles that that
seems to be first up on the non playing
season hit list
yeah he's gonna get traded and I think
that by franchising in which they are
expected to do they get to kind of
control where he's gonna go so if they
don't tag him which I don't believe is
gonna happen Nick Foles can be per se
the newer Giants if you want they're the
Washington Redskins if you wanted and I
don't think those of you wants that to
happen I think though about you would be
much more comfortable saying Nick we'd
like you to go at a conference to
Jackson though or we'd like you to go at
a conference to Denver or we'd like you
to go wherever it is but we don't want
you in the division so we're gonna tag
you now I know there's an issue that
they have to pick up the option which
they may do but they may just simplify
this in streamline and just say you know
what Nick rather than us picking up the
option and you buying it back to 2
million which you don't need to do let's
put the tag on you right now and we'll
go from there
I mean that would be the simple and
obvious rate of handling this it'll be
the most how do we say this the least
complicated way of doing it so I just
think that ultimately they are
determined to tre him and I think that's
what will happen well I mean with the
Giants though that would mean Eli would
do what tell him he's done or they would
tell Eli he's done for Nick Foles well
again III expect you are Manning back
and I'm not telling you that he like
Nick Foles gonna wind up in New York but
I'm saying the Eagles are gonna remove
that as an option to not even be
discussing the table I don't know how it
would play out
you know if the Eagles really big if the
Giants are able to get themselves a
quarterback that they really like and I
don't know if they like Nick Foles and
want to build around maybe at that point
time they sit down with you on that and
have a conversation with them we're not
even at that point I'm just saying the
Giants are at a point where they're not
gonna start looking at quarterbacks
figuring out what they want to do with
that position and whether or not that
would impact you like Manning now or not
now right now I expect you like man you
can be back but again they're gonna sift
through their quarterback options and
make a decision all right and last
football one for you Antonio Brown and
the and the Steelers I mean it just just
gets weirder is be honest with you I
mean juju Smith Shuster was on my show
last week called it the Kardashians and
it says that it could actually be all
put back into the bottle
run back as teammates with a big ben how
to use how do you see the next few weeks
on the Antonio Brown market playing out
Adam I think he why I think he wants to
be traded I think they're gonna have to
trade him and I think that'll be one of
the central storylines in the off season
where he goes because I think that that
relationship has just run its course in
Pittsburgh for everybody's sake I think
they'd like to move on from him I think
he'd like to move on from them and I
think that they're best off trying to
figure out a way to make it happen now
there are some teams I think that
ultimately be interested I'm not so sure
that San Francisco is the logical
destination that people have painted it
out to be but we'll see so again Antonio
Brown I believe which will wind up
getting traded ok let's talk about this
real supports piece it's it's lovely
Adam and I don't throw that that word
around too much it is lovely it's it it
captures you perfectly about how hard
you work and how hard you had worked I
was in closest to you of just around you
in proximity in the years when you were
working so hard at the NFL Network and
but your personal life you didn't have
somebody in your life and then you met
you met your wife in 9/11 Widow who you
have written about her late husband in
this beautiful pic this beautiful but
memoir the man I never met and Jon
Frankel the reporter who reported on
this also married a 9/11 Widow and the
conversation you had was just just
beautiful Adam and I'm wondering is that
part of the reason why you sat down
would you've not would you sat down even
with another reporter just you know you
knew John and you share so much in
common
well Richard you question what happened
was to be honest with you they reached
out to me about a month ago I was not
expecting it I was kind of surprised and
one of the producers there Chapman down
seven Lima hey any interest in talking
to us about your situation
I said sure of yours it now again he
said I think we're gonna have you to
Brian Gumbel or John Franco do it now
Brian as you know we all work together
yes NFL Network so I honestly was
thrilled and I happen to love real
which I sincerely mean I'm not just
saying that like that's one of the few
shows that I love watching on TV they do
an incredible job and so when they
reached out I was honored and flattered
I didn't have any restrictions or
demands like you have to do it this way
whatever they want to do is fine if
bryant gumbel done it i thought there
would have been a nice connection there
just because the fact that we all work
together you mean him and the first time
that I was a south on reporter he was
the play-by-play guy Chris Collins was
too busy analyst right was the sideline
reporter for NFL Network for our first
games so that would have been really
cool and meaningful to me but they said
hey we want Jon Frankel do I had never
met Chuck Frankel I've spoken to him on
the phone a couple of times when I first
started dating my now life asking for
advice because somebody had suggested I
should reach out to him look in the same
line of work and he had married a woman
ironically enough lost her husband on
9/11 and that guy that she was married
to was my college fraternity brother
Greg Richards Wow so oh yeah it's it's
wild so HBO for whatever reason decided
to assign John to the piece I think with
how the piece turned out that was the
right decision I think Brian would have
been phenomenal there's probably not a
better interviewer on television than
Brian and I would love to spend time
with him but the connection between John
I if HBO had set out to do a profile on
me nobody would have cared there really
wouldn't be much of a story but because
of that bond and connection I thought it
brought the story to a different level
and it was something that people were
not expecting and it made it different
it sure did oh yeah that's why the story
I think they did it like I said if
they're just gonna do a story on an NFL
reporter there are a lot of people they
could do that story on yeah because that
connection between Sean and I it made
that story unique yeah and then they
were you reached out to him for
information on what it's like I guess to
date and potentially Wed a 9/11 Widow
that was really moving as well you
really did do that huh back in the day
oh yeah a hundred percent basically when
I first met my wife
which would have been in July of 2006
it's it was very daunting and almost
intimidating to think that you're
meeting a woman who lost her husband on
9/11 who has a child and I had dated
different women in different situations
over the years but I'd never date
anybody in that type of situation and
because of that again I just thought
well I'd like to be prepared for this if
there's any way I could prepare for it
and somebody would suggest that I reach
out to jump right I don't remember who
that was but somebody gave me his number
I called them I'm sure he was like who's
this guy calling me for advice on how
you know dating a 911 Widow but I just
wanted to know what it was like if
there's anything he could say about it
if there's any do's and don'ts that he'd
recommend and we spoke at that time if I
remember correctly 10-15 minutes that
was it and the first time I ever met Jon
Frankel is when he walked into ESPN
about three weeks ago I conduct an
interview with me for the real sports
piece and I never met him in person
until then it's a great piece it really
really is and then I just loved seeing
the video of you back on NFL Network
back in the day man and I'm just assumed
you know it's funny they said do you
have any story that you're that you're
particularly proud of from your time and
NFL Network that you'd like to get on it
I said you know what I I couldn't think
of anything and then about two days
later I called up one of the guys
wearing a lik ethat were gathering
together some of the video for the piece
and I said you know what you need to go
get this story from about two weeks
before eating all of this rich two weeks
before I think we did 2006 and it fell
draft it was a fry it was a was oh it
was like a Tuesday or Wednesday
and I was calling in my topics to the
Barnea or neuro I might counter somebody
and and we were in the C Block with it
around the league segment you and I and
I said I got this item now in the year
that Reggie Bush was the presumption I
won't think that the Houston Texans are
really going to consider taking Mario
Williams number one
and I said it's so good it's so
interesting and so real and viable that
you need to move this up to your age and
make it the lead story right and like
come on I said I'm telling you so that
night we come on the air they do me a
favor that I requested of moving up to
the ACE I come out with you you say what
do we got today Adam I say rich the
Houston Texans are really considering
taking Mary Williams over Reggie Bush
which at that point on correctly from
London considered blasphemy on her
devising I think I said what are you
talking about or something like that I'm
like you what are you talking them
they're gonna take Mary Williams believe
me was on air fact I told them to get
that clip and and they didn't get that
clip unfortunately cuz I would I stole
you know what if you think think guys to
get that I would love to see that we
watch that right now yeah I mean you
could have sent them in my direction I
would have told him about the time
obviously were you with a false rumor
monger for Al Davis saying that in all
caps press release that you were wrong
about art art shell being fired no
matter what at the end of the season
that was true and then that was a done
and then the first night we went on the
air on Thanksgiving night your scoop
that no matter what Jake Plummer was
gonna do that Mike Shanahan was going to
turn to Jay Cutler and Pat Bowlen now on
the Pro Football Hall of Fame came and
found me in the Kansas City Arrowhead
parking lot saying where's Adam Schefter
and I never asked you this so I might as
well finish the interview following this
up did Pat Bowlen ever find you that
night in Thanksgiving you know what
first of all let me say congratulations
to the bone family yes I love that
family I know you love him hat I love
him he was so he and I spent so much
time in his office talking about life
and football and his team and and I'll
tell you a great story one year this is
also a great story they were playing the
Falcons in the Super Bowl and and so it
was Mike Shanahan against Dan Reeves and
Pat gives me of this big interview and
and and so he says hey Dan was the best
thing that ever happened to this
franchise and so I was transcribing with
tape and I went back up
officer hey you sure you want me to say
this that Dan Reeves is the best thing
that ever happened to your franchise and
he goes I said that I said get you
bitching that he goes oh no I can't have
that because it would have been like him
think he shot him like Santana the way
coach so I kind of saved him but he he
looked out for me so many different
times and I love that guy and never
found me at that but he knew I I don't
say this really he knew a lot of times
like that rich I would know things that
he was gonna find out and so that's just
sort of what happened that time and he
was always gracious she was never he was
never upset about anything ever reported
ever never he never once got mad at
anything
all those years that I covered that team
and that's why I love that man and his
family so much I bet I know you got to
go so and again we know you didn't send
real sports my way because you were
afraid that I'd get the tape of you
singing meet the Flintstones at a
karaoke at the Pro Bowl would get out
there if you don't want that in the
piece you are the best match I
appreciate it love you pal I know I'll
see you at the combine I'll see it the
combine that's our annual game okay bud
see you soon that's Adam Schefter the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience